okay so I'm Greg hi Jelena
like Coach chill on Instagram and
snapchat follow her there I'm checking
out more sketches in short films mainly
because I just love doing it too I want
to do more short films and sketches so
I'm just watching a little bit more and
doing that thing where I'm kidding I'm
gonna put my opinions on other people's
content out there and sit even good at
what I do
so yeah learning I'm gonna wall let
people watch me learn there's this
sketch totally from the channel totally
sketch called the expressionless now
this is from totally sketch which is a
sketch comedy channel but the thumbnail
looks terrifying so it could be funny
there is a puffy yeah this is from 2013
a long time ago but a couple of people
sent this over to me because I like
watching horror shorts
I don't like yeah I don't know what this
is gonna be funny all right yeah all
right let's uh alright let's just take
the gamble I like totally sketch there I
think they have some really [ __ ]
hilarious sketches but you know you
never know with these YouTube channels
sometimes they might just want to scare
you like it no oh my god I'm ready I
don't know it was scary if I punched you
scary for a lot of people end of the
year you know let's watch something
scary
okay this is a reaction video so you
have to watch you can't turn away
Oh
[Music]
those brains even the nurses ran away
hey it's not far from where I perfect
items read a doctor is crazy here
I need to try you're upset
but I need you to come back in there
with me calm no professional okay would
nipple chills oh hell no oh my god Oh
what is she
hi I'm dr. Richards excuse me the
problem today ma'am
[Music]
okay ma'am we're gonna put a harness on
you but your own safety up there on that
bad
okay nurses don't touch sure we'll be
giving you a mild sedative you may feel
a slight crack
[Music]
she's gonna fight him she's gonna bite
him
[Music]
the hearth
[Music]
I'm God fighting people
[Music]
ah I honestly thought I was gonna get a
little worse wow that was I was well
acted though yeah that chick whoever she
is she Tara yeah she was terrifying and
I loved the way it was shot and like had
this like I the way it was like gritty
kind of grainy looking and I thought
that the girl played the nurse yeah made
it that much scarier because she was so
terrified and it seemed so genuine
yeah like it looked like this woman
looks really scared and is trying to
keep her composure together and I
thought she did an amazing job the
doctor was good yeah I thought that was
like really well acted that seemed like
legit filmmaking a bellboy it didn't
feel like to sketch it felt like like
that of a piece of a real film yeah that
was really well made that was really
even though I don't like scary movies if
this was a home movie I might watch it
yeah I might continue on that was creepy
I wonder what the real urban legend is I
don't anything about it it's a it's an
actual urban life based on something or
like a creepy I totally forgot I am god
I would have said no you're not guys
white people what would you do what
would you what if this wouldn't be they
went through that
and you think that's they would like
religion like God or the devil I'm just
like absolutely terrified of anyway no
one shot her she did seem to have like
magical powers yeah but she didn't we
all that she can do like what if she has
other powers that we just don't know
about yes
yeah we don't know they said she's not
human I mean so know what's going on I
know it felt like they were just more
scared of who she was then really
realizing that she's just an insane
person what does she do she opens her
mouth and then she bites she's so scary
you know it's like hard to believe that
she could be normal
according to this she's a demon all
right all right well go with that yeah I
think it's much easier to sleep at night
believing she's a demon that was so
terrifying I think that but I'm scared
that I'm gonna see her face when I go
try to go to sleep tonight
well she didn't leave cedars-sinai
according to this video which is right
that mr. reach is not far from here well
thank you for terrifying the spores and
I thought let's watch a few fun videos
and then like malaria yeah I feeling
full spectrum of sure it's a journey
Wow always fun I hope you're enjoying
the journey it is quite the quest I
don't know I thought the creepy girl is
kind of cute you know over the actors
yeah when I go it's an actress yeah
definitely I'm like great I'm like I did
some makeup to her to make her look a
little like mannequin like you know what
she looks like in real life let's look
her up
I'm sure she's hot okay if you're new to
the channel please subscribe and
subscribe it totally sketch is one of
the 2013 videos they have a lot more
since this one Selina Meyers is light
coach chill on Instagram and snapchat
constantly snapping about her life how
she goes out in the day she's snapping
during yoga and she constantly any snaps
of people telling her you can't be
snapping during yoga please put away all
electronic
but she's like this is funny I'm gonna
keep snapping she's also the host and
coordinator of color my energy an
awesome event of all kinds of artistic
stuff from music to poetry to dance
every Wednesday 3rd Wednesday every
third Wednesday of every month in los
angeles california co al ho you are
don't forget to you why'd you put the
you in there we're unique unique get it
you just come up with that